can we get out in the field and see it
in action yep you bet beautiful scene
it's a good day for a flight
best of luck buddy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
this mag can fly seeing a man soar in
the air nothing short of majestic even
more so as it means my jetpack dreams
are alive and well but if the most
advanced jetpack in the most
technologically advanced age of the
world has ever known
still only gets us 33 seconds of flight
time well I guess we're not quite ready
to go full Rocketeer just yet that turns
out even though Troy and his team have
improved upon Bell's model fuel capacity
seems to forever be the jetpacks biggest
hang-up because a tank can only hold
what a pilot can carry at the present
time nobody has solved their problem you
have to have large canisters of fuel and
that's why Rockets are so big Rockets
are so big precisely because you need
large amounts of fuel to boost an object
into the air for more than a few seconds
the hope is that one day we'll have a
nano battery a power supply that is at
the molecular atomic level that is small
enough to put on your back or in a
Raygun or inside the engine of a flying
car that's the problem that we
physicists face miniaturization of
energy so while Troy and his team might
have only given us 12 more seconds of a
head time in the realms of futuristic
dreams maybe practicality isn't
everything the fact is this jetpack
technology isn't really ready for
primetime but we're working on it and
when you look ahead at what the next
great technological breakthroughs will
be maybe as so often it's science
fiction they lead the way what is the
rocket fuel that energizes science that
is curiosity I'm a physicist we never
give up on anything and until we can
solve the problem of energy concentrated
energy and a small scale then it's still
just a dream but I say dream on
[Music]
Oh